[Music]  Andy Richter and I have an incredible  on-air chemistry it just works  and I'd love to spend more time with him  off camera now Andy's never said a word  but I know he'd love to hang out with me  in my downtime problem is I don't have  much downtime which is why I invented  the cone drum cone drone get in here I  want you to go spend some fantastic  quality time with Andy Richter would you  do that  don't tell him just show up come on get  going  Andy's actually on a cook hello Andy I'm  here to spend some quality time with you  this is gonna be great Andy  hey who's this guy that was my  grandmother I'm not touching you I'm not  touching you  still not touching you not touching you  [Music]  could you get this thing out of my  office Prince thank you  [Music]